good to see you thomas nice to meet you
yuji huge congratulations on the new
season thank you
all right you have my first question
here so i just absolutely loved how much
chosen's personality shines this time
around and i'm sure you had a really
good idea of who he was going into
filming season five but were there any
qualities that you didn't discover until
you were on set actually working with
the material uh
i guess i try to prepare as much as
possible for anything that could happen
um but
you know
who would have thought that
you know the the whole club scene
you know
i didn't know what i was gonna do uh you
know i had all these thoughts in my head
do i do the robot do i do the you know
whatever dance
moves or whatever but i tell you it was
uh
uh one of those things where i did all
this physical stuff in in this club and
then
i
i said okay excuse me and i go to the
back i'm like
i was totally out of shape i said wow i
am winded from that dance sequence so i
tell you it was uh that was the only big
surprise was you know trying to figure
out oh shoot i gotta dance what am i
gonna do so
i was tickled by that it felt very
perfect to character so i like what you
went with there
all right thomas for you now
terry very clearly has a whole lot of
confidence in himself but at the very
beginning of season five what do you
think he thinks his greatest weaknesses
in this battle for the valley and beyond
if he thinks he has one at all
that's a great question i think you know
he it's he's still carrying that
ultimate betrayal by crease and
something he's devoted someone and
something he's devoted his life to and
to say
it's mine now i have to do it on my own
so with all his bravado i think they're
still underneath it and this is part of
the drive probably to go a little over
the top to say i have to make it work
because i've defined my life by this
it's such a huge part of my life i have
to make that work so there's that
desperation in there that i think um
worked for this character and you know
you could see and ultimately where it
led at the end with him all right let's
get into that ending now uh thomas i'll
go to you first so
terry clearly had no problem killing or
at least thinking he had killed chosen
and also ordering the senseis to kill
johnny but i was wondering what about
mike barnes was the plan to do the same
with him or was that a different case
it was a sort of a different case
because you know uh mike barnes was a
student and at you of mine and you
always think you know
you contextualize how where that person
fits into your world and that they
brought it back i i wasn't aware of that
what i was aware of was this formidable
opponent because
he sort of duped me by coming to my dojo
and pretending to be my friend and my
partner so building to that
you know chosen and terry just was just
it just felt electric and so right and
literally we say when the time came when
we faced off on set it's like the
creators were like all with their
cameras they're like little boys you
know fanning out oh this is just
incredible
and you just felt it it was like oh this
is gonna be a showdown it's like the old
western it's like let's go
that fight is epic and it's so
beautifully choreographed i especially
love the shot of you two uh like going
alongside the pool it's almost like
slightly silhouetted and it's just
beautiful ken barefield donnelly a stunt
coordinator and a fight choreographer um
these guys are off the chart talented
they made everything we do character
based and safe and they really pushed it
we said hey i got i got a skill sword
you know i started with a skill with a
sword and yugi had this thing and then
it was like oh my god we're going to put
this together it's like we could really
kill each other
and it's like they made it safe and
fantastic and balletic and just so
powerful all right yuji for you now with
that that ending uh fight set piece so i
know that chosen says at a point i am
not afraid to kill but do you actually
think that he would have done it in the
pool had johnny's yell not distracted
him in that moment yeah that's uh the
big question of the day right um
i think that uh
he would
have maybe back in the day he probably
would have gone full on just taking care
of business but i think there's that
sense uh of
you know daniel
you know in his head there's a sense of
miyagi in probably on his shoulder this
there's his uncle saying oh
jose you cannot do this you know so i
think he hears those kind of voices and
and he says you know um i did what what
i came here to do and that was to defeat
you and that was you know i think that
was enough um whether or not he follows
suit and
goes away
who knows we we have no idea but i think
perry
i was there and he was trying to kill me
okay
okay i was trying to kill him
no i wouldn't believe that for a second
all right i'll end with this one before
they kick me out here for you thomas
what do you think that season four
episode one terry would have thought if
he could see where he winds up in the
season five finale at that point when he
thinks he's on a better path in life do
you think he even had a clue of what he
was really capable of anymore
no
no i think
the events
that occurred brought him there
and then brought back these demons and
again he's holding on he's trying to
survive this is the path he's taken he
is fighting to hold on to something and
uh
i think uh if if that character could
you know see in the future he would have
been uh
i'm not going back no matter what makes
it even more heartbreaking and crushing
how all that found out but it's so
effective and i binge this one just as
fast as i binged all other seasons of
cobra kai so congratulations and thank
you guys for your time today thank you
so much